hey guys we are rolling on interviews
thank you
and if you do it once more i'll throw a
ticky fit
thank you for that
see
all right well this what you were just
saying this has been quite a week tell
me about your week here i mean oh how
can you ask for a better week than this
you get an emmy nomination and hot in
cleveland the the fun series that we're
all enjoying so much gets picked up for
20 episodes
i don't think i ever heard of a 20
episode pick-up i don't think i had
either
now tell we got them full
now is it is this show like what is the
chemistry like on this show oh i cannot
tell you if the chemistry between those
three girls wendy and
valerie and jane is just magic they
first of all they love each other and
that
that
shows
but it just they
you'd think they'd been working together
for
seven years
now and what about i mean because
obviously you add to that chemistry too
tell me about your chemistry with these
ladies well i i'd like to think and i
can deal in on a little bit because they
we just thoroughly enjoy each other and
the writing it's such a pleasure to get
the kind of writing that we've been
getting
so we just we come in and we start
giggling and scratching when we all meet
in the morning and it doesn't stop all
day
and your character how much are you like
here
that's a good question she's a pain in
the neck
but
but she's
she's fun to play because she tells it
like it is she just
she doesn't ever try to disassemble
now part of the premise of the show is
that
la is so cruel to grow old in for women
you know what do you think of that
premise i don't think that's true i've
grown old here i've been here since i
was a year and a half old which is like
maybe 10 or 12 years ago
but i find los angeles a lovely
place to grow old in but it wouldn't be
as much fun
for the show if we if we took that
premise so it's much more fun to have
them come to cleveland where things are
nice and solid and and all america
now
i want to hearken back to the emmy
nominations
and your competition i've heard from a
few people of your competition oh would
you say it's would you say it's tough i
i the other day
at the nomination when did they come out
thursday was it
i came home that night
and
here is this beautiful bowl of tulips
and roses and just a beautiful little
bowl and the card said
please mention congratulations on your
emmy please mention me in your
acceptance speech love tina fey
isn't that beer
and the course chris channel with what
will all and it's it's just
i can't believe being in that company is
lovely now i got to tell you what
kristen chenowitz said
she said watch your back betty i'm going
to trip her
okay
you got it
and if anybody wants to she's welcome
no she said she loved you too but it was
funny because she said
watch your back betty i will i'll watch
my back and i hope i find her there
now the other person who i talked to
that day was jane lynch who's in your
category too and she said oh no just
give it to betty it's already done
that's it
tina's are you kidding it's team well
let's just enjoy being in that kind of
company all of us it's just lovely
now
this show
is success this time around like you've
had so many shows that have been
successes this time around what makes it
special
the surprise element for one thing
because i i
i was just going to do the
guest shot on the pilot with the proviso
that i would not be involved if it got
picked up because my schedule's kind of
a busy one you know why don't we stop a
minute because you need a little queen
please darling i've got one here so we
were saying that you were only going to
be doing one shot
because i have a busy schedule uh i
i said i
i
couldn't be involved if the if the pilot
was picked up but i would love to do a
guest shot on a pilot
well
it got picked up in three i never saw a
pilot get picked up so fast so they
asked if i would do some more and i said
well that's the problem it's a it's a
busy schedule
well then they started you know well
what if you just do this what if you
just do that
and before i knew what i was saying i'm
yours sure because it it is such
i asked the girls the other day i said
what other business
can you go to work every day with people
you adore and get paid for it that's not
a bad line of work to be
now the chemistry with the crew and
everything i was talking with one of the
producers he said in his career too it's
been
the highlight of his career would you
say that this is
the highlight or a highlight for you
in all honesty i have to say it's a
highlight only because of the mary tyler
moore show and golden girls
but it certainly is
you don't expect another highlight at 88
and a half years old
now i gotta say you i was watching all
the episodes
and there is you had a line about a
canadian icon michael buble oh yes now
tell me about that line and canadians
might be a little upset with that one
well we don't want that to happen i
wouldn't upset canadians for anything in
the world i love canadians and i love
the way they treat us
and and the line was about buble being
you know uh you know a sinatra wannabe
what do you think of that about a
sinatra wannabe well
that's the part of having writing you
can blame the writers for everything
that comes out of your mouth
now what about carl reiner as your love
interest on the show
carl is just such a deer to work with
and
uh last
week before last
i had two men fighting over elka and the
other one was tim conway
and i must tell you that was a tough
week
i can't work with tim without cracking
up nobody can
and so i was trying to hold it together
but i didn't do a very good job
you